let's let's talk about what happened to
you joey you got uh yeah so so you have
something you got put on the no fly list
because you're because you're a dirty
person yeah yeah exactly they sold my
youtube account apparently but you know
it's funny man it's like so i had a trip
out in la i had to go
out to l.a for a wedding and some
business i get on the plane now mind you
i live in the south we don't have any
mandates down there i knew i had to get
on a plane i knew i had to wear a mask
so i go to the dollar store on my way to
the i almost forgot that i had to wear a
mess i just stopped at the dollar store
i get one of those gator wraps okay i
get one of those you know i don't know
what you need on there but i got through
the the security line i i got checked in
i get on the plane an hour into the
flight somebody you know they're doing
announcements though and this lady's
waving a little package with a mask and
she's just dangling it over me and i go
oh maybe they're just giving me another
one so i i didn't know and apparently 20
minutes later this lady comes up to me
and she looks like the jigglypuff meme
have you ever seen that the lady
throwing the temper tantrum
so she comes if you can imagine that she
comes up to me and she's pointing a
finger at me she goes mr borrelli you
agreed to the terms and conte i'm like
hold hold on we go who are you like
she's leaning over somebody's chair and
she's pointing my go who are you talking
to like this why are you pointing your
finger why are you yelling at me and she
goes do you want them to turn the plane
around like i just want to understand
what the hell is going on here and then
she'd go and i was like what do you mean
turn the plane around why don't you ask
everybody else
yeah they're like nazis i mean literally
that's literally you could hear the
whole plane could hear this i mean she's
so aggressive i have no idea what the
hell is going on she goes you agreed to
wear the approved uh diaper on your face
or whatever they call it so and i'm like
well i don't know i'm like how did i get
through screening how did i get out how
did i even get on the plane it's an hour
into the flame like i don't even i don't
even understand what you're talking
about and she goes well you want us to
you're going to be inconvenienced you're
going to be inconveniencing people when
we turn the plane i go no you're going
to be inconveniencing people i'm like i
don't want the plane to be turned around
why don't you survey everybody and she
goes well we'll see about that and she
literally stormed off like like a disney
character like just stormed off like a
little baby right 20 minutes into the
i'm just sitting there and the guy next
to me is like i can't believe this
happened i can't either on the con
on the speaker on the cockpit i hear an
announcement he goes uh
sorry to bother you everybody this is
the uh this is the captain in the
cockpit um here we're we have a
passenger who's uh refusing to comply to
the mandates uh we're gonna divert the
plane to memphis tennessee uh we're
probably gonna lose an hour or so so we
apologize we're gonna make it as fast as
possible and then and then the
jigglypuff comes back up to my scene she
goes that was for you and i go good how
how much are graceland tickets because i
never been before i'd like to check it
out so now everybody's laughing on the
plane and she's getting pissed off right
then the gestapo shows up an hour i'm
about almost an hour from la now the
gestapo shows up and they're all staying
they're like the little rascals the
jigglypuffs behind behind the guys who's
the gestapo like it's the whole squad
like six agents show up it's right like
flight attendants
yeah yeah so they're all pointing
fingers i'm like what is what point in
the fingers i go i don't understand i
was like can you tell me the difference
between this mask and that mess and they
go you agreed i'm like i understand but
i'm like i'm just trying to figure i'm
just trying to have a conversation i'm
like is it protocol to just point your
fingers at people and start yelling at
them i'm like we could have a civilized
conversation but like the fact that
you're just nasty i mean like what
airline was it
american airlines stalin airlines
apparently if i was wearing a joseph
stalin mask maybe it would have been
fine but this was not an anti-mask thing
and just to clear it up i'm not
anti-mask i'm anti-you or anybody
telling me how to manage my health i
think that should be my personal
decision or i should rephrase force me
well so okay so what ends up happening
so what ended up happening was that they
gave me a piece of paper that says if
this uh if this experience heightens or
if there's something more happens you
know if you know if i start bucking the
system more then you will be greeted
with a person
um in the airport and and you know and
they'll probably find me or ban me or
whatever but it never said that i was
banned i had the paper and so sure
enough nothing happened and i go to
check in today to get out here and sure
enough they go oh well you didn't comply
and i go well this was already resolved
and i was handed a warning they're like
no they said that they sent you an email
that you're banned from american
airlines i'm like well i never got that
and i go and i never not complied like i
couldn't even have a conversation i
tried for four hours to have a
conversation with these people but well
we'll have to you're going to have to
call customer service and i'm like i'm
looking at it you gotta cut i mean
that's why i'm talking i was at the
airport for two hours and she goes well
you gotta call i go see this is the
problem like nothing ever adds up
everything's inconsistent i finally get
the manager the manager finally comes
and then she goes will you comply and i
go you could have just said this in the
beginning i'm like of course i never not
wanted to comply i go but i look i grew
up in new york if somebody comes up to
you on the street they say the words
comply yes they said you did not comply
they said and they said that that's what
it's about yeah under the boot
yeah take the blue pill why didn't they
literally give you a mask on the plane
they tried to in the beginning they gave
it to me but at the time when that lady
gave it to me she didn't say anything
and i thought it was an extra one
because i didn't know at the time that
you needed an approved mask i didn't
know there was any different i've flown
before
during the pandemic and i remember
wearing a bandana and all this i didn't
know what changed because mind you i
live in the south we do where i live we
don't have mandates so we just you know
we think that we've moved on from but
once you get on that plane you get out
there you know not a lot of states have
moved forward so i understand the
federal law and i like i said i even
went to the store to get the damn mask i
wasn't trying to be anti-mask or
anything like that but they they had me
boxed in as if i was and they're saying
i wasn't complying i'm like
i told you i grew up in new york it's
like somebody points a finger at you and
starts yelling it's like i don't want to
have a conversation with like have some
like you're violating the civil
obedience you know what i mean it's like
like like b is a civil human being i
don't understand this aggression that
people have it's almost like a religion
like a cult and like they think they're
doing so like just okay i didn't
understand why don't you treat me like a
human being you're talking to me like a
dog they talk to you like a dog people
have gone insane this is something that
we've noted
at some point
something happened where everyone just
became vile yeah all of a sudden
civility in any capacity i'm not talking
about politics i'm not talking about uh
you know discussing religion or money
you know the three things i say not
supposed i'm talking about
all of a sudden
gradually then suddenly people i knew
who used to be like hey uh you see the
new episode of you know whatever show
and i bet oh cool now they message me
being like this is some stupid fa and
they're yelling and they're angry
they're messy i get messages on facebook
and they're just pissed off about
everything and i'm like why are you so
mad
calm down don't tell me to calm down you
have no idea i'm like dude
you know what i don't i got locked in
they got locked in their cubicles and
their concrete blocks smelling like sour
milk these big cities exactly for a year
exactly
i'm passionate about stuff too but i
don't get worked up i don't get angry
like that i mean somebody sent me a
message the other day and they said that
that i'm an upset donnie wahlberg on
valium which i think is a i guess it's
an accurate
i mean i just don't get excited i don't
get excited like that you know what i
mean to to yell i mean like and what
does it cost really to take people's
civil liberties away your salary you
know what i mean is that all it causes i
mean these these people are being used
to be soldiers for for an idea that half
of them don't even believe in
you know what i mean they do and that's
that's the scary thing when you look in
their eyes and you see that like they're
doing something i'm like you're gone
like i is how so here's the funny thing
right
this is how nazi germany happens now i'm
not saying it's identical history
doesn't repeat it rhymes what i'm saying
is when i make comparisons to what we're
seeing now in the united states with the
conflict the split the cult
people say i'll say like you know civil
war tensions spanish civil war weimar
germany and they'll say oh it's not like
the nazi germany blah blah i'm like not
yet
so did you think that when it came to
like the spanish civil war one day
everyone woke up and said guess i'll go
fight my neighbor no there were tensions
brewing for a long time weimar germany
you think people just woke up one day
and said i really don't like that group
of people no it was a long period of
time where they kept doing things and it
was increment after increment after
increment right but we look at history
and it's condensed we say and this year
this happened and then all of a sudden
you get this and it's like dude right
now we are seeing
you you see these videos right where the
woman's sitting at the table and they're
screaming black lives matter and they
get in her face and they hold their
fists to her face like it is it is
psychotic mob yeah who does that remind
you of nothing
look what happened with netflix outside
of netflix yeah when you got the guy
holding the sign saying we like dave so
they attack him
steal the sign destroy it then claim
he's got a weapon get in his face
screaming shaking a tambourine yelling
repent i heard his video was taken down
on twitter as well
yeah for copyright claims but this is
what happens when you have such
psychological abuse that has been
represented in the mainstream media
showing you grandma's gonna die
grandma's gonna die it's gonna be
horrible people are gonna suffer but you
could stop it if you're just enough of a
karen and they give people a little bit
of authority that little bit of
authority goes to their head but they're
psychologically thinking that they're
doing the right thing that being tough
on you as a little peasant slave as a
little peon as a little person that is
supposed to obey everything the
government
decrees
that they're in the right because
they're going to save lives by doing
this when in reality that that is
further from truth than i think
a lot of people people
i think people get power over i think
it's like you're giving people that
typically don't have power power the
everyday person that works at the store
or the flight attendant it's like they
get off on it because they don't have
that power typically so when they're
they're handed that power look what they
do with it i mean that's why we do have
issues with cops in a way that that
abuse their power and stuff it's like to
give a citizen a badge and a gun or a
power over somebody it's like you it
proves that you they don't it's hard to
find good help obviously because there's
there's not a good enough screening
press nobody should be pointing their
finger and mind you this one was 100
pounds overweight i'm not trying to fat
shame here but like i don't think that
she was really that concerned about her
health to be honest but she's she's
acting like it is the mask is the wrong
word
vaccine is the wrong word mandate is the
right word comply
comply you know and here's the thing
if you're rich you don't got to comply
no you can get a private plane you've
got to worry about it you get a private
car you don't have to worry about it you
don't have to adhere to any of these
rules and if you're really rich you
don't even need passports right like
billionaires when they fly into
countries they don't need passports yeah
what was that of an event with the
celebrities the met gal or that was the
with the what's her name but you know
it's like it what do they say right
rules for for thee but not for me i mean
it's it is what it is you can't expect
celebrities to have to abide by rules
the rich they're better than you and
they know it and people don't see that
and they and they still knock guys like
us you know that that are able to break
that spell it's all in front of our face
right now when when people became vile
and you know i'd see somebody on
facebook and their comments would just
be like this thing is making me really
angry and i'm furious and they're stupid
and this slur and that slur
that rage
well when they're at their job and
they're flipping burgers and you walk in
and you're not abiding by the rules
now's their chance to get their anger
out there's a video where a guy is
chasing a woman who's not wearing a mask
and he says does anybody else think it's
wrong that we all have to wear masks and
she isn't
and she's like get away and the people
are like get away from her dude like
calm down yeah i mean that's a perfect
representation of what's going on
psychologically in everyone's head that
you pinpointed very well there tim
because
again i i still can't understand but but
when i do
i i can't understand when i hear stories
about what happened to you it's hard to
fathom because it's just weird to
understand that people could be so mean
and rude to each other but then when you
do look at what a lot of these people
are are fed on social media when you
look at the rage bait when you look at
the echo chambers that are just
regurgitated on them 24 7 that they
can't escape
um you could see this kind of
indoctrination being laid on very thick
very heavily and it indoctrinates these
people to double down triple down on
these kind of larger ideas that they are
the ones that are going to save everyone
yeah by policing everyone and and that's
a delusional belief that's absolutely
very dangerous and it's it's the same
idea that was used in germany it's the
same idea that was used in in communist
ussr uh
countries it was the same ideologies
used by many dictators by many despots
all throughout history because they know
if they could psychologically
manipulate someone to believe that
they're doing the right thing
but at the end of the day they're
serving their purposes they're going to
do it willingly and their agenda their
narrative is going to be rammed through
as quickly as it can this is what uh
gina carano was trying to make uh that's
a point and she lost her i mean she
didn't lose her career but like you know
i mean like she lost a big opportunity
there yeah she's not gonna be saying
don't demonize your neighbor yeah and
she's not gonna be in season two yeah
she's one of the good guys she made that
exact point
that you brought up to him that i kind
of expanded on a little bit she made
that exact point and she got cancelled
and kicked out of a major series
uh
for even mentioning with all the actors
even standing by being like wait what
she was a major part of the series why
can't she come back
why because she's she's speaking about
things that absolutely make perfect
sense
you